through someone you've worked with that  you expected them to be one way and they  turned out to be completely different in  a good way i hope  i i was really uncertain about kevin  costner i got to tell you he's again one  of my best friends now and he turned out  to be the kindest smart  um even though he didn't direct water  world he kind of did and then open range  he did direct and michael gambon and i  played the two league bad guys in that  and i would spend night after night at  kevin's house uh in the in the beautiful  rocky mountains up in canmore alberta  watching him edit smoking pot with him  every night and watching him edit  and edit and have a glass of wine and  then learn from him um  i was stunned at how warm kevin is to  everybody and how smart he is if you  [ __ ] him he'll he'll he'll put you in a  headlock and he won't let go  but he's uh he turned out to be like  what a what a jewel kevin costner